the azov style steel works the largest
of its kind in Europe and the Last Stand
in the Ukrainian defense of mariupole
hold up in here are soldiers Marines
Medics and hundreds of civilians
the plant is cut off but from one Marine
inside answering our questions a blunt
assessment of the situation
um
foreign
[Music]
appealing to the world for help says
they are almost defeated
foreign
[Music]
fighting around the plant has been
intense humanitarian corridors out have
now failed over several days this
footage gives us a snapshot of what's
happening on the ground shared on social
media in the last 24 hours we have
analyzed and geolocated it it shows the
site from the southeast smoke can be
seen rising from a number of buildings
in the center of the complex and in the
site's Northern section
four strikes are visible a second later
another two explosions can be seen
and another in a courtyard in front of
the buildings another explosion can be
seen on the Northern perimeter of the
site just 10 seconds later
to the northwest of mariupole zapparija
is where the evacuees should be arriving
but the car parks where thousands were
welcomed just days ago are now empty
on the wall inside the processing tent
the faces of the missing alive or dead
many of these people lived in mariupole
among those who have made it out Olga
Makarova and her son Timur
her story is just awful
she describes how her little boy was
making his own earplugs to muffle the
sound of War
away from the devastation in Kiev an
offer from Ukraine's president Russian
prisoners of War for the safe passage of
Ukrainian civilians and troops
we are ready to exchange our people for
their prisoners
they have left corpses and their people
in every war there is always a place
which comes to represent the heart of
the horror here it's marry you pull Mark
Stone Sky News in eastern Ukraine